we saw her get too psyched cuz he  haven't sold it yet there's a 30 day  period where if everything goes well you  cook what the hell is going on over  there hi we're your neighbors welcome to  cap the new is that a Greek respawn oh  it's our sorority what are we gonna do  maybe it's not that bad girls are  usually quiet no they kill the girl the  new buyers are not gonna want to live  next to a sorority we need help let's  shut this party down on the theme song  mark my length of Lexi's it disguises  everyone you look like a psychopath  people love clowns oh stop doing that  happen new will defeat you yo I'm their  butter wrapper oh that's a good one it's  a little hard to call cops without a  phone give us that back no  it's called cork dumbass zoom those  girls are out of control where's our car  lindo enough [ __ ] they come back kappa  knows doesn't he was my soul hasn't left  a dent if I've been no  let's get flash on